like the big fights
the kids doug doug is our lawyer my
cousin
the little baby are they babies no
they're oh they're adults yeah i thought
you're saying that you have little
there's one little
baby yeah oh i thought little diva was a
kid i'm sorry
i didn't know no ash is a baby yeah
i'm so confused i am too i thought you
guys talking about there's a bunch of
kids running around there
are there's i already know jessica's
baby quinn oh i know that one who's
frankie
my friend megan move on from it okay
um i read this article george and i know
i'm not a parent so i don't know if this
is um i know that it's really annoying
to hear parental advice from someone who
has not birthed
a live child but i read this article um
on the guardian that said there's two
things that
you can't if you do you you you will
probably have like
a pretty balanced kid
is don't yell and don't over celebrate
them
and i was like what do you mean don't
over celebrate you can't be like oh my
god god
everything and everything sometimes you
give this is what they tell you to do
give him like a smile and a nod
and that kind of loving like um kind of
like that
validation or that affirmation of saying
oh like that but to be like
dude that's what parents do they just
put their kids on this pedestal too
but you're my kid okay okay come home
and say that you won oh my god
you know you once like you're now your
grandmaster they just gave you
you're the grandmaster a chess
grandmaster hi papa you know how i
played test at school
yeah i vaguely but yeah okay you told me
to but i
i know i got you a chest set but i
didn't know that you were competing but
the grandmaster said i'm the best in
class no you're a grand master you're a
grandmaster
like as a kid yes they're a grandmaster
kids
oh yeah
don't change characters dialogue
uh at school today that um i just got
awarded
grand master chess player i'm really
good oh
okay don't don't say it's okay no that's
what you want
no you said that that's a good thing not
to open
hey mom i got grand master chess that's
amazing sweetheart congratulations i'm
really proud of you
that's not over that's not over
complimenting no over compliment
do the thing the parents do i just got
grandmaster in chess i'd be like oh my
god let's go tell your dad but what is
over
like a small little thing is like a oh
my god good job sweetie
but even things that aren't big like you
know what i mean like because if he said
he would have grand master i'd be like
where are the newspapers but what
parents would do this to like bring the
newspaper people over tried banana for
the first time
yeah oh they celebrate that oh my god
i would never do that like the given
that you should eat that
that's what i'd say so um i have some
advice i guess okay okay
my advice is um have you been putting
um headphones on the belly no i haven't
done any mozart no that's what i'm gonna
do
that's what you're going to do no we're
going to put
beethoven rock monolith we're going to
put classical music
in your belly yeah 12 hours a day oh
white classical can it be like some [ __ ]
like maybe some rye throw some rye in
there that is good
yeah and maybe some [ __ ] um you know
beastie boys or whatever you know okay
yeah yeah but
mainly cyprusil but mainly it's going to
be like chopin
and stuff so it just when it's in the
womb it absorbs
i think that that's going to do
something okay right
and then um so that's number one so you
didn't do that no
not yet not yet you still have a month
i would do that number two i'm gonna do
the pool thing
what's that oh they put the baby in the
bottom of the pool
you throw a baby in the pool and it just
can breathe underwater oh my god i'll
find it
like right at birth you mean yeah yeah
oh yeah but
that's i think you you'd want that can
breathe under what do you no you don't i
wouldn't just
throw a [ __ ] baby in the pool i
wouldn't do that but you're saying
you almost got it you gotta admit that
almost
i've seen it on youtube you throw the
baby in the pool you take it learning
how to swim that one
no we're the big give that i saw the
whole learning how to swim one is just
basically teaching the baby to rotate on
its back
like to flip over it that's all you're
not talking about you're not talking
about this right
yeah that's that's it they they they
learn baby
it's not the first time the baby is in
the pool
it's a slow it's a slow step it's a slow
process to get there
i've taught little kids this isn't you
don't just do that first day that's
crazy
the kid will drown who's the pioneer
baby for this [ __ ] yeah yeah god
what if i just threw the baby and just
turned around and walked away they're so
smart that'd be so sad
look at that yeah but this is not the
first time the baby is doing that
it's a learning yeah how does the baby
not know to breathe in the water
it's i mean honestly like when would
like is that
not a human instinct to not breathe in
the water
oh yeah that's a good point that's good
that's a good point it lives
lived in amniotic fluid for nine months
in the water
that's a good point all right i don't
know babies all right i forgot
hey guys we're gonna take a really quick
break to share our amazing sponsorships
brooklyn is my favorite sheet
in the whole wide world in the whole
wide world
yo you guys um i'll tell you right now
um i only use the best but when it comes
to sleeping
i only